if you're in the process of creating a
new life then it must mean then you must
have a very clear intention of what that
new life would look like and that's a
function of the brain and and the brain
is the architect it is the Builder the
frontal loobe switches on and it's the
creative Center and you ask the question
what would it be like to be wealthy what
would it be like to be healthy what
would it be like to be happy and your
brain actually starts looking for
answers and the frontal lobe begins to
to access the association a circuits in
the brain that are connected to that
question and so if you're truly
beginning to imagine whatever that
future is and you start falling in love
with that future before it happens it
takes a function of the heart and we've
discovered along with other institutions
that the heart has a very profound
effect on our biology marry the clear
intention the function of a coherent
brain with an elevated emotion a
function of a coherent heart and you do
that properly and you start to change
your energy hey it's EV car Michael and
I watch these videos every day because I
need them for motivation being around
successful entrepreneurs every morning
helps me believe that I can do great
things too it's like your morning coffee
but for your goals kickstarting your day
with a blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
hash believe in the comments below so I
can celebrate with
you
so today let's learn how to make this
year your best year ever enjoy is it
possible then you start to see effects
in your life you know things start
coming to you instead of going and
getting them somehow you start seeing
these synchronicities these
opportunities these coincidences that
begin to mysteriously appear in your
life now when that
occurs it kind of wakes you up like huh
it's kind of weird that that kind of
happened that kind of synchronicity is
weird like I didn't really plan that I
didn't really expect that that's the
Awakening right to prove to you how
powerful you really are and in fact can
begin to create events in your life and
instead of going out and going and
getting them or having to do things to
get them somehow they seem to come to us
rule number two is follow your intention
with Dr tarus wart Bieber intuition is
the lessons that youve picked up along
the way that you're not conscious of but
they're still stored in your nervous
system
and so the less conscious you are of
them the deeper they're pushed into the
nervous system so there's a process
called hebbian learning named after the
neuroscientist Donald Hebb and that
is it's basically you know neurons that
fire together wire together but it's
that the things that you've learned
today like things that you've learned by
speaking with me that's going to be very
front of mind and kind of just in like
little Pathways that are just kind of
connecting up with each other but stuff
that you learned when you were five like
when you put your hand in a fire and it
burnt you and you never ever want to do
that again that's deep down you're not
really conscious of that but you know
and and other things maybe that you
don't recall so we believe that your
that wisdom gets pushed from the outer
cortex into the lyic system which is the
emotional system of the brain into the
brain stem into the spinal cord and into
the gut neurons and that's why they
sometimes call it gut instinct because
it's that feeling of knowing something
but not knowing why you know it um but
it's actually to do with the fact that
you have wisdom and
experience that is it's in it's it's
embodied in you but you're not conscious
of it necessarily rule number three is
focus on the present moment with echar
tole do not be attached to the fruit of
Your
[Music]
Action which of course simply
means
do don't look to the the goal of what
you want to achieve through whatever you
doing now give your complete attention
to the doing rather than where you want
to get to through the
doing and that's again very important
lesson nowadays because most humans
don't know that yet they are always one
moment ahead they want to to get
there you may find in your own life
still a lot of the
time you are not present moment centered
you are focused on the next moment that
you need to get to so whatever you are
doing at this moment is
designed to get you to the next moment
and
internally you project yourself away
from what you're doing now because the
doing becomes a means to an end
this is very normal everybody lives like
that whatever they do is a means to an
end and me in their mind the end is more
important than what they're
doing that is so habitual and
unconscious that most humans don't even
know that that is how they live that
they always live for the next moment but
they're never completely in this moment
they also don't know that by living in
that way they create frustration and
suffering and stress and
discontent basically they're condemning
themselves to continuous discontent and
to stress because if you ignore the
present
moment
continuously and ignore means you make
it into means to an end because the next
one is so important that you need to get
to then you miss life completely you
miss the depth that potentially is there
in life and life becomes shallow because
it's all mental because the next moment
is always a mind formation the next
moment is a mental projection the next
moment is never a reality because it
doesn't
exist when the next moment comes Okay
one minute from now I've got one minute
to finish
[Music]
this and then after 1 minute it's not
one minute it's oh it's now
again and then the next thing to do of
course immediately you look to the next
thing because you have
become used to be uncomfortable with the
present moment condition since childhood
to feel ill at ease in the present
moment oh I should be doing something
and doing
implies some future
projection you you can never be you're
always doing also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is own your mornings
with Mel Robbins when you wake up
generally what the research shows is
that your brain is primed to be able to
focus for the first 4 hours of the day
the first four hours of the day tend to
be for most of us the time of day when
your brain has the most fuel and when
your speed of processing is awesome and
when you are able to direct your
attention at what you need to be focused
on okay so now there's a caviat to this
you can manufacture boosts of
productivity and boosts of feeling like
you've got a little bit more brain power
number one immediately after you
exercise so so if you have a burst of
cardio 30 minutes is what a lot of the
research says but if you have a burst of
cardio you will get a little bit of
increase in fuel another thing that
helps is getting outside getting outside
uh when you start to feel your energy
and your focus start to go to empty
getting outside is another way to give
yourself a boost of brain power but
generally speaking everybody
you need to start to marry mornings with
Peak productivity if you can own your
mornings if you can put that thing that
matters to you first thing in the
morning and make a little bit of
progress on it you are going to start to
feel like you are more in control you're
going to start to see yourself using
your best brain power and your highest
level of fuel at the thing that matters
most to you r five is fix your
environment with Robin charma I think
it's really wonderful to have a great
lifestyle um in the 5 a.m. Club I share
a lot of the ideas that have been very
helpful to me in terms of building a
beautiful lifestyle it's really
important Environ an environment your
ecosystem is going to drive your
performance so being a round art um
there's a model in the book called joy
as a GPS releasing toxic people and
populating your life only with people
who fuel your joy yeah going traveling
there's a lot of good good signs coming
up that traveling boosts
creativity uh Prosperity is very
important you can do beautiful things
for your family so I think living a
lifestyle that inspires you and that is
beautiful is so great for your craft and
so great for your creativity and so
great for your productivity I think it's
really important to surround yourself
with people who are curious and have
high integrity and who stand for
possibility and who are all about
growing and doing their to make the
world a better place rule number six is
be patient with Gary ve one of my
favorite things to talk about is
patience I'm obsessed with it I believe
in it the most I think it leads to very
good behavior I think impatience leads
is often an indication of insecurity
rushing for success to show others not
themselves and so for me I push patients
a lot I'm stunned by how many people
struggle with me pushing patience cuz
they hear
complacency cuz you know and and I'm
fascinated by people's inability to
balance words that may seem in
contradiction to me I'm as ambitious as
they come I'm hungry I'm sitting here
today and there's not a person in the
audience that scares me that they're
hungrier because I don't feel fulfilled
I'm still super driven I feel like I
haven't even started and so I sit here
hungry but I equally impatient you know
when when you know when I hear about my
life Lo and gold to buy the New York
Jets right like a lot of people now that
I'm in public figure like when are you
going to do it next year next and it's
funny I see all these people out in the
open at the happened today at the
airport at in nework guys's like when
are you going to buy the Jets and I'm
like 32 years and like the
disappointment in his
face and and so I I think people
struggle to balance what may seem like
contradictions and I think in that
there's something important to dig into
and rule number seven the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
keep going forward with David Goggins so
this is where the 40% rule comes in
people worst shape my entire life I've
been through Ranger school Delta Force
election twice three hell weeks all this
crap this is the worst pain I've ever
been in to this day I'm 43 years old
right now to years in the military I've
done 60 Ultra races pullup records all
kind of stuff this is the worst pain of
my entire life to this day but this is
when I had to realize one thing I had to
break this humongous thing down to very
small all I put in my mind was let's not
quit yet I'm going to quit but not yet
so I sat there I can't stand up so let's
get some nutrition all right I'm not
dizzy
anymore let me clean this crap off me
okay I need some food I'm going to quit
after eat a peanut bur and jelly
sandwich all right but not yet let me
see if I can stand up stand up maybe
I'll quit let me see if I can walk to
the car there's the car it's a one mile
track I walk past the car I'm going get
back to the
chair I'm not going to quit yet I kept
this mindset the whole
time I end up doing 30 more miles did 31
miles truthly after that did 101 mil in
19 hours if you driving the car the car
may say 130 M an hour the factory puts a
governor on it so it only go 91 so
you're sitting there when to race
somebody they they have no Governor
they're fine boom you can't cuz every
time you get 91 the car starts doing
this starts doing this we put a governor
on our brain and the second we get to
that Governor our body start doing this
oh this sucks this is uncomfortable no
no no no no let's go this way let's stop
it starts giving you all these questions
that we cannot answer if you can't
answer the questions your brain is
asking you you quit if you have the
answers to those questions of why the
hell am I out here and you give it a
quick answer the brain starts shutting
up because it knows why we're doing what
we're doing I started figuring these
things out in my life so we have this
governor on our brain and how you start
pushing past that Governor start
realizing your brain has the Tactical
advantage over you why because it knows
you're your insecurities
it knows when you're lying it knows your
fears it knows everything about
you what is it you've seen people do to
turn up the heat to take things to the
next level so I say two things the first
is just staying consistent on the thing
I don't know how many times it took you
to make a video before your channel
started to take off uh for me it was a
lot you know just I had I don't know how
many years five years to get to 2,000
subscribers or something like that it's
just the only thing I had going for me
was I just kept going right I I wasn't I
wasn't very good on camera I didn't have
any strategy I didn't really know what I
was doing I felt insecure all the time I
was introverted and shy and like not a
natural Entertainer but I just kept
going and so a lot of times the answer
is just keep going just stay consistent
just make another one just make another
one and I think if you if you're always
focus on the next one you're making and
not so worried about oh my last one
didn't do as well or wasn't as good a
thumbnail or whatever like okay just
like you sucked it perfect make the next
one keep going there's always another
one that you're going to keep doing
that's the only thing that I had going
for me in the early days and a lot of
times it really is just continuing to
show up because in the showing up you
will slowly get better you might be
naturally talented amazing but you will
even if you suck you will get better you
will slowly get better at the skill and
opportunities will come to you uh if
you're in the game but like you don't
get opportunities if you're just sitting
thinking about the game you got to be
there in the game and a lot of times we
feel like we're just striking out and
striking out striking out but it's like
it's another bat and then eventually you
get a hit you know and then you keep
striking out and you get another hit and
you slowly get better you can play
forever right I mean it's like you can
keep doing this it's not like in a year
YouTube's going to go away and now
you're not going to be able to make it
so just showing up consistently and for
me it's having a calendar and videos
have to go up so this is something I
talk to creators about all the time is
for us it's a daily calendar for
somebody else it might be a weekly or
monthly calendar but a video has to go
up every
day even now how many years later 15
years later whatever it is I still don't
100% love any video that we release
right like I look at like oh we could we
could tweak that and we could change
that the int that's such a huge Point
yeah it's like we could there's always
something that we can tweak and fix and
if you give me infinite time with it
I'll keep working and keep working and
keep working and keep working on it but
a video has to go up today and a video
has to go up tomorrow so we do the best
that we have with what we've got and
then tomorrow we release another video
and so nothing gets in the way of the
release schedule so we haven't missed a
video upload in over a decade I don't
know you can go on the channel I guess
see when the last time we didn't have a
a day of making videos I think one of my
first things in
Failure is don't take it more personally
than it actually is and I'll give an
example of that when I was applying to
40 companies that all rejected me before
an interview yeah all I was getting was
an automated response saying your
application will not go any further I
can't take that personally because they
didn't meet me in person they didn't
have a interaction with me they just saw
my name they saw I'd been a monk for
three years that resume is useless I
mean what's your transferable skills
like sitting in silence and Stillness
surprise surprise no one wants to hire a
monk and so they rejected you but that's
not personal because they didn't meet me
in person but what if they had meeting
you in right so that's the first step
the first step is don't take all fear
failure I'll give you an example me and
you we reached out to countless guests
to be on our podcas who say no all the
time who say no all the time but if I
don't hear a no from the guest directly
that's not a no like someone's team can
say no someone's assistant can say no
someone's P team can say no but until
they say no personally it's not a no
okay but when they do say no then that's
a no yeah so then let's move how do you
deal with that type of failure yes so if
I deal with a failure where someone
meets me in person and gets to know no
Jay you're horrible stck like I don't
want to deal with a monk ever in my life
I would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah then how do
you deal with that type of so I've heard
you say this I've said a couple of times
and I'm sure it's been repeated a bunch
of times around how I genuinely believe
failure has feedback feedback and and so
for me it's like failure has the ability
to actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention improving to get the actions
that you want to take yeah the results
you want
you want and don't make that about the
who said no don't try use failure as a
way to prove someone else wrong what
happens when we prove others wrong when
you prove others wrong you end up trying
to get validation and approval for them
and now if they're not impressed when
you're right you lose again so you end
up losing twice you and you spend all
this time and energy years maybe to
prove someone wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment and then I feel empty again
totally and and so that's the thing
about failure in the second off is you
have to see failure as an improvement if
if I'm completely honest everyone who
rejected me in my life up until now has
made me more hungry taught me so much
more about myself and made me up my game
yeah and I think if failure doesn't make
you up your game it's the same as losing
in a Spore right when you fail and
you've lost games and you've won games
you on the big stages you didn't have
the skills you didn't have the teamwork
you guys weren't hungry enough whatever
communicating enough there was something
you were missing so you go review the
game film you check the stats you see
what could I've done better and you try
to improve that for the next game yeah
and I think a lot of people can do that
in life but we're so afraid to like go
on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going you
know in sports luckily there's a season
it's like you might have 30 basketball
games after you lose the first two you
don't say uh I'm just going to give up
the rest of the season you keep playing
yes but in life a lot of people stop
playing yeah why yeah I think that's
great mental training too I think Sports
is great mental training because you
have to show up to the next game even if
you lost and you don't feel bad that you
don't feel good sorry and and one of the
things before I dive into that question
one of the things that you reminded me
of was the The Last Dance documentary so
there's that season that Michael Jordan
everyone is agreement in in agreement
that he is one of the best players to be
playing and and they keep losing they
didn't make the finals right they didn't
make the finals they lost and then they
realized they need to get the team and
they need to find the I think they're
bring in Dennis Rodman and then they
start bringing in all these other
players that strengthen whereas if they
would have just said oh we got the best
player in the world we just keep doing
this I'm not sure they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and and how do we deal with
that I think we feel that pain because
we look at a f
right we look at it as a complete
definition of us right we're looking at
as as there's that famous statement of
like you know failure is an event not a
person right and I don't know who said
it but it's one of those statements that
that really clicks like failure is uh an
event not a person whereas we start
thinking we are the failure like we say
I am a
failure have you ever spent any time
wondering how does everything happen how
does everything happen why does the
night follow the day why doesn't the day
follow the
day fact in some places it does
but I spent a lot of time thinking about
this fact at times it almost drives me
crazy but like right outside of my
studio here is a Japanese maple tree and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful in the spring of
the year it has buds on it then the buds
boom and leaves pop out and the leaves
generally in the spring are a very deep
greeny Brown they're not a pretty
looking Leaf but then they start to
change and over time you don't notice it
happening just one day you look and it's
a different color and by Fall the leaves
are crimson red they're most beautiful
it is the most beautiful tree and it's
right outside of my studio I'm sitting
here in my desk ask and the camera's
around me but out there is that
tree and you know every fall the leaves
turn
red Every Spring they're greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the fall and greeny brown in the
spring think about it did you ever
wonder why the tide goes way out the
tide comes way back in I spent some time
in the Navy in kenned and I was down on
the East Coast for a while and I was
near the Bay of fundi do you know the
Bay of fundi has one of the highest and
lowest tides in the
world it's absolutely amazing it goes
way out and then comes way back in same
up around Prince George on the west
coast you go on to a ship and you might
be walking up a plank just right
straight up and you go off the ship
sometimes going right down that ship
goes way up in the air and it comes way
down very high very low tide now some
place the Tide's not very big they do
have a tide but not too high not too low
why is it so different one place than
another you know why does the leaves
change color why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know just stayed at a
certain length you wouldn't have to cut
it but it would always look pretty
you know do you think about this do you
know that everything in this universe
happens in an exact
way an exact way not by chance but in an
exact way when John Kennedy the
president of the United States act as Dr
Warner Von Brun who was the master of
Mind behind the Space Program when he
asked him what would it take to build a
rocket that would carry a person to the
moon and bring him back safely to Earth
Von Bron answered him in five words the
will to do it that's it the will to do
it he knew you didn't have to know how
to do it he knew you had to learn how to
do it but you didn't have to know to
make up your mind you were going to do
it now why did he say that because he
understands the
laws Von BR one time said after years of
studying the spectacular Mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of God and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise that we don't even have any
difficulty building spaceship we send
people of the Moon and we can time the
landing with a Precision of a fraction
of a
second now he said these laws must have
been set by someone I see the laws as
God's motus opendi but I'm going to tell
you something everything happens by law
when you and I get in harmony with the
law now we do that ODS are pretty good
we should understand them but when we
get in harmony with the law then I'm
going to tell you it's just smooth
sailing
success
happens probably be a good understand
good idea to understand the laws
wouldn't
it think about
it your life is governed by laws that
are not man-made so they're not going to
be man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them I'm going to
You'll shock you yourself with the good
you can do now I've been doing that for
the last 58 years I'm starting to get a
really a reasonable grip on them but I
don't understand them as well as I want
to or would like
to but I'm going to study a little more
today you know I get my trusty book out
here I have to talk to you about this
book that'll be another
talk study the laws find out what they
WR what they're like what are the laws
and then study them
you'll win broadening your awareness
starts to create brain coherence and
when the brain starts functioning in a
more orderly and coherent way and it
begins to synchronize and those
different compartments of the brain
start working together there comes a
moment where the two hemispheres of the
brain start to synchronize into balance
and the union of polarity the union of
opposites the union of Duality is called
wholeness and now we are creating from
wholeness instead of from lack or
separation and this is where it gets
exciting because when a person does this
properly and they can practice it our
research shows that people can change
their brain waves in one second in 4
seconds in 5 seconds in 12 seconds and
13 seconds and 19 seconds why because
they understand the process of getting
Beyond themselves so why is that
important for you because up until this
point whether you know it or not you
have been the process of practicing
brain coherence the first part of the
formula and
so when you open up your awareness in
your next meditation I'm going to ask
you as if you had no eyes no ears no
body to feel to smell to taste as if you
were just an awareness I'm going to ask
you to sense this Blackness and I'm
going to ask you to sense its depth I'm
going to say how far can your awareness
go into endless space and all I want you
to do is sense its infinite depth I'm
going to ask you to become aware that
there's infinite Blackness on both sides
of you and all I want you to do is
broaden your focus and to sense it to
feel it to stay connected to it and the
act of opening your awareness in sensing
space slows your brain waves down I'm
going to ask you to become aware that
there's Infinite Space behind you and
the act of sensing that Infinite Space
behind you causes your brain to start to
fire more orderly we've measured this
thousands of times and as if you were
just an awareness in that Blackness I'm
going to say to you now it's time to
become nobody no one no thing nowhere
and no time and take your attention off
of everything known into invested into
the unknown and like investing into a
bank account the longer you Ling in the
unknown the more you create
possibilities in your life and if you
find your mind returning to your body to
your pain to your drives to your
emotions to your habits to thinking
about certain people or objects or
places or things in your known
predictable reality to thinking about
the familiar past or the eventual future
simply become aware that your attention
is on the known investing back into this
threedimensional reality stop relax
return back to the present moment and
unfold back into possibility into the
Blackness you say that we have to master
the concept of the present moment what
does that mean well there's so much talk
about the present moment and being
present in the power of now but um most
people
um they spend the majority of their life
uh 95% of the time either living by some
past emotion or some past habit or
anticipating the future based on the
past and so we're very rarely in the
present moment and and paying attention
is being present and it's a skill just
like anything else the more you practice
it the better you get at it so think
about it if feelings and emotions are
the end product of past experiences and
you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
if you wake up in the morning and you
have to search for The Familiar feeling
called you every morning and and that
feeling is unhappiness or frustration or
lack or insecurity or
fear the moment you get in touch with
that emotion you're starting your day
from the past because the emotion is a
record of the past now if that emotion
is connected to memories that are mapped
neurologically in your brain of certain
people at certain places at certain
times with certain things then the
moment you feel that emotion you
associate that emotion with the past
memory then you're activating circuits
in your brain from the past so if how
you think and how you feel creates your
state of being and thoughts are the
vocabulary of the brain and feelings are
the vocabulary of your body then your
entire state of being is in the past and
most people are living in the past so
their body is their unconscious mind and
it doesn't know the difference between
an experience in their life that creates
an emotion and an emotion that they're
creating by thought alone to the body
it's exactly the same so those emotions
start driving people's thoughts and if
they can't think greater than how they
feel and feelings have become the means
of thinking and they believe that their
thoughts have something to do with their
Destiny then they're thinking in the
past so they're creating more of the
same life and by the same means if they
wake up in the morning and they come
back to their senses and they start out
with the same routine that they did
yesterday and they're going through a
series of routin habits of going to the
toilet making coffee eating breakfast
taking a shower driving the work the
same way then we could say for the most
part a person's future is nothing more
than a replication of the past and
they're not in the present moment and if
they keep doing that over and over again
that becomes a habit and a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's
acquired through frequent repetition The
Habit is when you've done something so
many times the body has become the mind
so for most people their body is
dragging them into a predictable future
and they're on autopilot based on what
they've done in the past and they've
lost their free will to a program I
think anybody who is alive right
now who is engaged in
life has noticed a
quickening uh taking place in other
words everybody feels like more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time
so there's an acceleration and time is a
construct in our mind there's no
circuitry there's no Hardware in our
brain to be able to understand time it's
a construct based on our past and how we
predict the
future
but
information is so readily available in
our world right now that in an age of
information ignorance is a
choice so you don't need an authority to
gain information any longer you don't
need a priest you don't need a governor
you don't need a doctor you don't need a
teacher you can access information at
your
fingertips so then as you begin to
discern the information with discernment
the proper and right
information you begin to develop some
type of empowerment because all of a
sudden you're seeing
possibilities that you never saw before
without that so you wake up you become
more aware so the knowledge creates
awareness awareness creates
Consciousness Consciousness and energy
are connected so there's a change in
energy globally going on with the world
now that that that knowledge and that
change of energy has effects on
paradigms that are no longer a
vibrational match with that new level of
Consciousness so you see a political
systems unraveling you see economics
economic systems unraveling they're unsp
spiring they're unraveling they can't
sustain themselves with this new energy
you see
journalism the environment education
religion uh uh medicine it's all
unraveling because something greater has
to come as a result of a change in
Consciousness now no victims here
because you and I
negotiated from a soul level to be here
at this time this is the time we've been
waiting for this is this is where it's
happening in the Milky Way this is it's
happening here because there's a true um
Coming of a new Consciousness it's not
one person that's
coming it's a group it's a collective
Consciousness that's emerging and
emergence is uh one mind one
heart and the way you control people is
you give them misinformation based on
emotions you control people by
controlling their emotions and media and
television and advertisement is a great
seduction that people can watch uh the
news and get really angry then change
the channel and watch a football game
and get very excited then change the
channel and uh watch a Sit calm and
laugh and change the channel and watch a
drama and and you can change your
emotional state because of
technology so then it means then most
people are relying consciously or
subconsciously on things outside of them
to make them feel a certain way and so
my interest is to provide the proper
content of information scientifically to
people so that they reason that this is
actually possible then to give them the
opportunity to experience that
philosophy and get their behaviors to
match their intentions as many ways as I
can now if I do that properly people are
going to have new experiences the
experiences are going to change the
circuitry in their brain learning makes
connections but experience and riches
connections the end product of an
experience is an emotion so when you
start feeling worthy when you start
feeling a love for yourself when you
start feeling A Love For Life when you
start feeling truly grateful the moment
you feel that emotion you're teaching
your body to understand what your mind
is understood and living in stress is
when your response to the
environment causes you to activate the
autonomic nervous system and when you
act activate that autonomic nervous
system a branch of it called the
sympathetic nervous system the fight ORF
flight nervous system is mobilizing all
of the body's
energy all of the body's resources for
some danger in the outer environment are
you with me still and it mobilizes all
this energy to prepare the body to do
one of three things to fight to run or
to freeze and hide and so the
mobilization and tapping all of the
body's resources causes the heart to to
race respiratory rate to increase pupils
to dilate digestive juices to shut down
blood sent to the extremities the immune
system dials up then dials down we
mobilize all this glucose to have the
energy to be able to run figh or hide
now in the short term that works really
well all organisms in nature can
tolerate short-term
stress the human beings were a little
bit more
complex sometimes it's not the Predator
that we're afraid of it's the person
sitting next to us at work sometimes
it's the news sometimes it's a reaction
to someone or
something and the constant knocking the
brain and body out of balance causes
that imbalance to become a new balance
and now the person is headed for some
type of breakdown some type of disease
because no organism can live in that
state an emergency state for an extended
period of time
I know you all have big goals Big Dreams
big aspirations just like I do youve got
Ambitions to become an amazing person to
build your career to create to
contribute to give to be an awesome
human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you you'll fall off and and
and having new goals without new habits
is kind of like you know having a new
car without wheels you know that habits
are the wheels they're the things that
make you able to achieve the goals so
you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
at the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out more on a more regular basis
and then it goes away or you say you
know I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like what what happened I said I was
going to be nicer it's that you didn't
set up the most important thing you
needed to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments you have to set up
trigger moments to activate your habits
what do I mean by that well let's say
you want to become a a better person you
know you want to become more kind more
patient more loving with people now you
can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision your journal or
set up on a vision board that you look
at once in a while but in daytoday life
it's not enough you need things to
trigger you to remind you to be that
particular kind of person right it's
almost like if you could have a little
angel speaking in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become better
well that makes sense well let's use
that idea let's use that idea by setting
up alarms on our phones that trigger us
to do the very things we need to do this
is going to be so basic you're going to
laugh and then I'll also tell you how
I've literally taught this to Fortune 50
CEOs and they said it was the one thing
that changed their life the most
dramatically so let's start with this
let's have a goal in mind let's say you
want to become more present and calm
throughout the day again you could write
that down on a jour I'm going to be more
present and calm you could meditate in
the morning say today I'm going to be
more present and calm and you you could
you can start out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said close your
eyes take 10 deep breaths in remind
yourself to be calm so let's say you're
going through your day it's crazy right
it's 10:00 a.m. and all a sudden Bing
your phone goes off you look down and it
says close your eyes take 10 deep
breaths and then again it happens at
2:00 and again it happens at 6:00 p.m.
and again it happens at 8:00 p.m. what's
going to happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that that changed
everything and you'll think once you set
it up that the next day you you'll
you'll forget about it no that alarm
will go off you forgot you set the dang
alarm there it goes off in your face
you're like all right I'm trying to be
calmer and more present close my eyes
take 10 deep breaths reground myself
here we go you can't do it once a day
you have to have moments throughout the
day that trigger you to enact the new
Behavior I know this makes sense to you
but it's a challenge for a lot of people
because they never set those things up
so what if you did it with an alarm so
for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes now at 50
minutes the timer goes it starts buzzing
and I look at that and I go oh that's my
trigger to get energy so I stand up I go
get some water I take a glass of water
drink it down I do some stretches and I
do some exercise just really briefly or
I'll go for a walk whatever it is but
I'll do something that usually takes
just 2 to 5 minutes then I'll sit back
down I'll set that 50-minute alarm and
I'll work and what that does is every 50
minutes it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two 3 4:00 time where I'm like ah
you know why because I've triggered my
day so that my energy is maintained
throughout the day makes sense right
this could be as simple as let's say you
want to be healthier in your life okay
let's set up some trigger moments for
you in this way let's say every time you
drop off the kids on the way back to the
house you stop at the grocery store and
get some fresh produce that's just a
trigger it's like okay did one thing
drop kids off now tied to that triggered
from that action drop kids off is go to
health food store or let's say you want
to get healthier in the morning one of
the easiest ways to help people maintain
a better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on uh might get dressed
if you were naked just saying so you get
dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
doorframe triggers what do you mean by
that when you walk into a new room to
have a psychological trigger go off in
your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
if I've been working all day and I'm
going to walk in I'm going to see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said the three words
said the three words and I did this so
many times that now when I walk through
a door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words so what words would
you love to have describe you as a
person that you would be happy if that
was how people described you what would
those words be have those and now set
them up in your life I teach Executives
to do this as well I have them have a
doorframe trigger when they walk into
their office in the morning as soon as
they walk through that door frame they
have boom three words go through their
mind about how they want to be perceived
as a leader I have them set up another
door every time they walk into a meeting
into the conference room when they walk
through the door of the conference room
they have another three words that
trigger off for them and it just reminds
them how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people they think they
have to completely change their life
what would change your life completely
is setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you uh
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that your
inter interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes I
would credit much of the success I've
had to whatever extent I've had success
to learning how to write and practicing
writing and the reason for that is that
without writing it's very hard to freeze
your thinking on paper so that you can
sharpen it so that you can see where for
instance using words that aren't well
defined where you're saying things that
don't need to be said all of this will
help everything else I remember in
college for instance when I took a class
with John MC an incredibly gifted writer
and teacher all of my grades in every
other class went up because every the
extraneous bit of information that was
hurting instead of helping me was taken
out so to sharpen the saw a couple of
different approaches number one is write
anything anything whatsoever stream of
consciousness essay doesn't really
matter let's just call it one to three
pages something along the lines of
morning pages and Julia Cameron the
artist's way popularized this there are
a number of folks like Brian kman very
well-known writer screenwriter
co-creator of the show billions by
morning pages so that is an easy way to
ease into the practice of just moving a
pen I recommend freehand so that you can
see your thinking on paper that
accomplishes two things number one it
takes the anxieties and nebulous worries
in your head puts them down in a freeze
frame so that you can kind of trap them
in the printed form so you can get on
with the rest of your day the second
thing it does is it allows you to see
where you are sharp and where you are
dull in your thinking now if you are
drafting as I do for instance right now
once a week writing if you are looking
for a proof reader and you do need a
proof reader if you can't find a
professional writer because we can't all
find professional writers talk to
friends who have any type of legal
training or you could even hire a lawyer
to do this or a pargal someone with a
law degree they are trained to look at
language very very carefully because in
a dispute in a negotiation in a
disagreement arbitration it's going to
come down to the wording of contracts
and I have found that when I not have
access to professional writers it is
often times just as good or even better
to get lawyers or people with legal
training to read my writing so that
would be a workaround that I
accidentally discovered that is very
powerful you're going to find the
meaning in your life by
adopting by adopting maximal
responsibility right that's going to be
extremely difficult CU you're so bloody
useless you can't even get your own
house in order and you're and you're
going to be called upon not only to get
your house in order but to do that well
enough so some woman can stand having
you around for more than like 15 minutes
in the back of a car and then maybe
you're going to have to do it so that
you could be a good father to a family
and a pillar of the community and that's
not just empty words it's like if you do
that nobly there'll be something to you
and then when the storms come you won't
be blown over by the first 4 foot wave
and young men think huh mean I could be
something that wasn't blown over by the
first 4 foot
wave I think oh well that's that's
that's inspiring maybe that's worth
doing a little work towards it on the
off chance it might be true and the
thing about it is it is true so it's not
that difficult once you understand it to
make a case for it it's true and it's
also true that you grow in proportion to
the weight you take on voluntarily and
it's also true that we have no idea what
the upper limit to that is right so you
know you you've met remarkable people in
your life people can do remarkable
things and there are inevitably people
who take to took on remarkable burdens
and because they did that their
development was forced by necessity they
were forced by necessity to grow beyond
what they were and who knows what the
limit to that is
the one reason that most people don't do
entrepreneurship is they do fear
failure and I think a lot about fear and
failure I think one of the great things
that happened to me was I did love
sports which meant I lost a lot and then
with school I was losing so much in
fourth fifth 6th seventh grade that by
the time I was 14 I was used to losing I
would argue I loved losing I think it's
why I love being a Jets
fan I'm being serious I'm being serious
I think that is a
characteristic of an entrepreneur and
that was a huge characteristic of mine I
think a lot about the kids that I see
now that run away from playing something
cuz they're scared to lose for me I was
the reverse I would play and play and I
would cry I cried a lot when I was a kid
if you want to know about me I cried a
lot at 9 10 11 12 but I would just get
up again and play and get up again and
play and I think we've done a terrible
job in our society on demonizing losing
when we give kids eighth place
trophies we we confuse them you
understand we start to tell them as
parents losing is bad so we have cuz
they know I promise all the parents in
here when your kids eight and they get
an eighth place trophy they know it's
weird and when we give them that trophy
we're telling them losing is so bad we
need to like cuddle your feelings and
we're going to give you this bull
Trophy and what ends up happening is it
doesn't set them up for real life
because real life happens and it doesn't
work that way you have to clear your
calendar certain times and do the tough
stuff if selling is the tough stuff
schedule it from 2: to 3 from 5 to 7 put
it on your calendar and don't allow
yourself off the hook until you do what
you said you're going to do so powerful
so true you know I I we've been helping
Tony and I obviously we own Mastermind
and we help people with our programs and
courses to sell what they know to share
that your greatest asset is your life
experience how to turn it into a course
a coaching program a podcast a workshop
a book right we obsess on that but we
know sometimes people get through all of
it they life experience is priceless all
these pieces and it's time to sell it's
time to Market sometimes the wheels come
off sometimes we get a little
intimidated I get that but if you fall
in love with what you do it's a lot
easier when you feel it's a disservice
not to get them get it to to in people's
hands so you can help impact them that
starts changing but then you start got
to start getting tactical you got to
start getting
repetition so here's what I challenge
you this week challenge you to look at
is where in your life do you need
Improvement okay I hope it's in your
business hope it's in
sales or I hope it's I hope you just
recognize what it is I'd recognize the
hard part is it if if it's your
relationship is is the hard part having
a conversation about a certain thing
that you really need to talk
about is it in your health is there is
there something you that you just keep
putting off I don't want to cut out the
bread I don't want to go to the gym I'm
embarrassed to go there is it in your
business is it doing the marketing is it
doing the sales is it you put put
yourself out there is afraid to go live
afraid to do a video here's my challenge
to you in this short own your future
behind the scenes podcast this week
figure out the things that you are
putting off that you are avoiding that
you're a little a little scared of or
just a little uncomfortable with and you
just keep working on the things that
aren't actually moving the needle in
your life moving the needle towards the
manner the woman you're meant to be
you're kind of putting it off till next
year next month and you'll never do it
unless you do that one thing I started
this podcast off with time to schedule
it it's time to schedule it so your
challenge recognize what you're putting
off recognize what's uncomfortable
schedule it and then the best way to
make it happen is to remind yourself why
you're doing this in the first place get
leverage when you think I don't want to
make that call but I want freedom with
my family I want to be in control of my
calendar I want to be in control of my
life whatever it takes to get the
Leverage The Tool the asset the the the
compelling future running away from Pain
do whatever it takes to get Disturbed
with your own inaction schedule and then
hold yourself accountable for the
results that you want to
achieve we got to stop lying to
ourselves saying we're going to do
something say we want the success say we
want to make the sale say we want
freedom and then we keep letting
ourselves down because it's
uncomfortable that can end today this
week if you so decide you've heard this
phrase that first you create your habits
and then your habits create you I think
one of the challenges when you are
working from home or you traveling is to
establish structure because a confused
mind tends to not do anything you may be
one of those individuals like me that
need structure and by having a routine a
set of behaviors they provide a system
something I could go to and that reduces
something called decision fatigue a lot
of times if you have to think about
things that you are doing on a regular
basis too much it could expand a lot of
energy and one of the challenges people
report in our private Facebook group and
our app and our social media is they
just feel exhausted and part of the
exhaustion comes from using your brain
overloaded in too many ways so what I
would say is have systems and so for
example for me I have my morning routine
and you've heard me talk about this uh
maybe on our podcast maybe in our books
and our courses some things that are
specifically for getting my mind right
first thing in the morning I believe if
you want to win the day you have to win
that first hour of the day you have to
win that morning and my goal is really
not to distract myself so when I wake up
first thing in the morning I will go
through and I will say okay what's the
most important things I get done today
cuz it's not about being busy right
we're addicted to busyness sometimes we
say oh people ask how's your day and
what are you up to I just like I'm so
busy and and we use busyness as maybe
like a badge of honor and what we're
really saying is that we're busy so we
must be important but the goal is not to
be busy because then we start designing
our day around being busy and we wonder
why we're stressed we wonder why we are
overloaded so what I do is I say okay
let's say and do this with me please
Wherever You Are in your day right now
if you were to fast forward at the end
of the day and somebody was to ask you a
maybe a family member or friend how was
your day and you said wow it was amazing
today was an incredible day I crushed it
reverse engineer it what had to happen
in order for you to say those words what
happened during those days what things
did you accomplish who were you being
doing sharing and so on for me I think
of three professional things I want to
accomplish I feel that if our to-do list
is 20 things or 50 things or even 100
different things then we're just being
busy the most important thing is to keep
the most important things the most
important things and you could do
anything but I believe you can't do
everything certainly you can't do
everything at once so what would three
wins be for your day the reason so many
people aren't productive throughout the
day is not only because they don't have
their purpose and their psychology and
their physiology supporting them but
also because they're going through the
day in an ignorant way you know they're
going through the day Focus solely on
responding to everybody else's
emergencies you know here's what most
people do they wake up they get ready
for the day they go through the they go
to work they're not really thinking
about anything yet they're just kind of
going through the motions they get to
work and what do they do they open up
their email inbox which is the worst
thing you could ever do to be productive
your inbox is a nice organizing system
of other people's agendas that's what an
inbox really is it's a nice organizing
system other every email in there is
someone needing something from you or
pulling from you that's what most of
them are isn't it true and so what most
people do is they open up their inbox
and they start responding to other
people's emergencies or they start they
start looking through all their emails
to see well what am I supposed to do
today or what's the biggest fire I have
to fight today in other words they're
living their life in
reaction versus living their life in
intention in intelligence in Direction
they're not focused on what to do
throughout the day they're just saying
well I'll do this because that's what
popped up today you know so for
personally I never even check email
until 10:00 a.m. when I get up and I'm
looking at everything I'm sit down and I
strategize my day before I ever even
think about checking my email and then I
might only check my email once or twice
a day because I set up all other systems
to support my ability to be productive
because in your life I'm guessing that
you're only really making money if
you're producing and in my my industry I
live in the experts industry that's the
sort of the self spirituality business
growth world where we offer advice to
other people about how they can improve
their life or build their business
that's the expert industry in the expert
industry most people are really
struggling to be productive because
we're creatives right we have so many
great ideas and so many great intentions
throughout the day and we have so many
ideas we can never actually accomplish
them maybe you're the same maybe at base
you're really a Creator and you have all
these ideas of so many things you want
to do but you've never really been able
to organize them and get them done
because you haven't set up system to
support your levels of productivity
let's start with at the beginning of
your day uh I'm going to just jump into
one little thing that I do at the
beginning of the day it's not the very
beginning but I think it will help you
and it's a way of organizing my
day and I call this onepage productivity
it's just a simple sheet of paper that I
have that I fill in when the morning
after I've gone out and I've exercised
that's a piece of my morning activity is
mastering my physiology so I can become
a high performer starts with me drinking
lots of water in the morning eating the
right things going for a little quick
run or workout or even just a brisk walk
to energize my body and my mind so that
I can be creative and think and when I
get back to my office and it's time to
actually work I do this onepage
productivity sheet and this onepage
productivity sheet helps me really think
through what I need to do throughout the
day so here's the three elements of this
and by the way below this video you can
download the sheet and you can use it on
your daily life let me walk you through
how to use it basically there's three
elements of the onepage productivity the
first element is Major
projects these major projects usually if
you any given person probably has oh I
don't know you know like three big
buckets of projects that they're working
on so I might be working on you know
writing a new book I might be working on
doing a new seminar I might be working
on you know reinvigorating my online
marketing those are big big these are
big bucket projects that aren't
necessarily they're the priorities for
the day these are the big Vision these
connect me to the what are the big
things I'm doing and any given person if
they're well organized they're probably
only working on three maybe five main
projects so what I want you to do when
you start out in the morning to keep you
big thinking big and thinking outside of
just the day to focus is you know and in
in High Performance Academy we've
already talked about purpose so we're
already engaged there okay this is just
a little snippet I want you to think
about the big picture of your projects
and I want you to think about what are
the five
things that you would have to do to move
these projects forward this is not five
things that you need to move them
forward today that's your priorities
your projects are just in general what
are the big things that you need to do
the big five things you would have to do
so for example if online marketing is
one of my big projects in rein one of
the things I might have to do is learn
to code a web page right or learn to
design a web page now that's a project
it doesn't mean that today I'm going to
learn how to do it it just means in
general that's one of the things I will
have to do so these are what are the
five big things You' have to do to
actually make that project come into
fruition what would you have to learn
what would you have to go out and master
what would you have to who would you
have to contact what are the things you
would have to do for your big projects
next is people category in this people
category I want you to think of two
things in the people category the people
category is really important for high
performers because High performers
really get ahead not just because of who
they know but how they're engaging who
they know right what they're asking for
what they're doing so the people
category that I want you to think of
each morning on this onepage
productivity is two categories one I
want you to sit down and think of who do
you need to reach out to today who do
you need to reach out to so if I want to
learn coding as an example in general I
might want to schedule some time with a
coder or web designer so I'm like I'm
going to have to reach out to a Cod or
or web designer today and this is
important because most people when they
open up their inbox they just start
replying to all these things when I open
my inbox the first thing I do is I send
out these emails people I need to reach
out to it's the first thing that I do
when I open my inbox as an example very
first thing is send out all the emails
that people I need to reach out to the
second category
here is the people that you are waiting
on right given any person's real
schedule you're waiting on somebody to
give you some information or a decision
to move forward in your day isn't it
true you're waiting on something from
somebody so that you can move forward
and most people they just sit there and
they wait for the the email to pop up
they they hope that it's going to come
they don't do anything about it the
second thing I do when I open my inbox
after I reach out to the people I reach
out to the people who I'm waiting on and
I say something specific to them so let
me give you an example how this actually
might operationalize in the day when I
open my inbox I'll look in my emails for
these people first and foremost it's the
first thing I'll do after I send out the
ones I need to reach out to
strategically I'll say who am I waiting
on I'll look at and I'll open up their
inbox or open up their email to see if I
got what I needed if I didn't I send an
email right back to them to make sure I
get what I need as fast as possible so
yes there's an element of you hounding
people to become productive you know
most people are just sitting around
waiting for other people to help their
dream dreams come true for me I'm
chasing people down right you know I
want to for high performers there's a
level of impatience there you know if
you want to become a high performer you
got to have this level of impatience
that says I need to accomplish this I
need to do this let's go let's go let's
go you need to be on a faster path in
life not stressed out more but more
focused on achieving what you need to do
to become happy to become successful not
just because someday that's going to
happen for you but in the moment in the
moment being happy and success uccessful
so that you can be happy and successful
hope that makes sense ultimately that's
the people category then the next
category is the priority category okay
your priority category is what are the
10 things that you've got to accomplish
today these are the 10 must do items
this is sort of like your to-do list but
it's ranked in the order of most
importance it's very simple right cuz
to-do lists are great I'm all for them
I'm all for day planners because it
helps you achieve some of these things
but at the end of the day you got to
think about okay what are my real
priorities today and here's what I'll
often do depending on how big these are
and how important they are when I get to
my when I've written all these out
here's how my day works here's the order
of things that I'll achieve throughout
the day first I'll do whatever it takes
to achieve these priorities whether it
is sending an email or whether it is you
know running an errand or whether it's
call calling somebody these priorities
in my day happen first often before I
even open my inbox or if I have to open
my inbox I'll wait but priorities first
accomplish these first no matter what
these get done first before I respond to
anybody else's emergency or go through
all my inbox these
first then I move up second I'll go okay
who am I waiting on and who do I need to
reach out to the people category I'll do
that now often this will take most of
the entire day and then I'll say if
there's any given time left in the day
I'll Focus back on the bigger projects
thinking about what it's going to take
to accomplish
them to shape your reality watch the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there how can people begin
to attract the life that they want to
bring abundance into your life you have
to be cultiv ating an abundant mindset
and so a really easy way to start is to
list the things that you're grateful for